we're taking this red carpet very
seriously that's why we're asking
everyone to wear at the world premiere
of Star Wars The Force awakens in
Hollywood and we're getting celebrities
to do their best Star Wars impressions
that was Chewbacca so let's start off
with something easy can you do a
Chewbacca impression I need a really
loud walk asking everyone to do their
best impressions of other characters so
can we get a Tupac Aurora nope no
Chewbacca roar embarrassing
okay marks and that was great now is it
a pause thanks Carrie I'll do it with
you if we do it together will you do it
Harrison told me mine was awful can you
do better thank you
yes Luke liked it han Solo hated it you
guys have to decide do you think you can
do an r2d2 be for us have an r2d2 beep
beep pretty solid all right oh no no I'm
going to use a BBA what you sound like
boop boop beep you probably just like
Hurst in r2d2 or something how about a
lightsaber noise
pretty solid I think you nailed that
thank you
nice talking to you that's like more the
chef mr. Tom Cooper yes what can I have
a word